I don't want another baby right now but
I want like seven kids but not right now
one down six more to go Kylie Jenner is
opening up about her future plans as a
mother
[Music]
on Friday the 22 year old hopped on
instagram live with her bestie Stassi
after the two played a game of would you
rather they opened the floor for fans to
ask questions another baby I don't want
another baby right now but I want like
seven kids but not right now I'm like
anyone but of course I want like I wish
I could snap my fingers but pregnancy is
just not a it's it's the way pregnancy
is set up it's not a joke it's a serious
thing and it's hard not ready for that
right now Kylie having seven kids would
make her the kardashian-jenner family
member with the most children
outnumbering her mom Chris who has six
and Kim who has four the makeup mogul is
already a mom to two year old baby
stormy with rapper Travis Scott last
month she shared on Instagram that
keeping her pregnancy with stormy a
secret and not leaving the house for
months prepared her for self quarantine
when it comes to keeping stormy busy
these days
the reality star says she's bought a
bouncy house a slip and slide and other
outdoor games to keep her entertained
adding that as a kid she has no idea
what's going on in life amazing
[Music]
yes
Kylie's future baby plans were revealed
during the do your part
Instagram live series based off the
views during their livestream doordash
is donating 2.3 million meals to
families in need through their
partnership with feeding America last
month ET spoke with Caitlyn Jenner about
how her kids were coping during these
times they're doing very well I think
Kylie's happy because she's at home and
spending a lot of time with stormy and
she loves that
kylie is calm body Kendall likes getting
out but she loves being at home she
loves cooking loves being you know with
a little stormy and she's doing just
fine
[Music]